last week we tried out the Joop cologne
for men because Tracy Morgan had
mentioned it in his live episode at the
Beacon Theater yes we had our thoughts
and it ended with you going home
smelling like a bucket of Jupe to see
what kind of reaction you were gonna get
yes I wanted we wanted to test to see
what my wife's reaction would be without
me saying anything so
um this happened last week
drove home from the podcast Studio to
make sure because I had some Jupe on me
that we applied uh during the podcast to
make sure I got out of my car in the
garage and I sprayed underneath the
right part of my throat and the left
part of my throat and then rubbed it in
because I wanted it to be powerful
um super duper exactly so I walk in I go
into the kitchen
um my wife's there and the first thing I
wanted to do was give her a big hug so
that she would really smell it
so at first I think she was concerned
because I was coming in for this big hug
and
um you know we haven't hugged since I
think 2006.
um that was yes according to the lawyers
it's 2006. uh but
sorry going for this hug and I think
she's a little bit like huh okay all
right I'm getting a big hug from Conan
this is nice and then her I I
intentionally made sure that because I'm
taller than her she's quite tall but I'm
taller than her so that her nose is
right up against and she went oh
Euro and she stepped back and she went
you're wearing a cologne and she's being
very diplomatic because
um what if I think her initial thought
was my husband is now a guy that wears
cologne and this is what he's Conan yeah
and
um how do I get out of it this is who
you are now your cologne cologne I'm
cologne Conan and uh so she said oh and
she was so she didn't have like oh my
god what the you know she just said oh a
Colona said yes do you like it and she
was like um yeah and she's being very
diplomatic oh how nice and she's being
sweet because this is you know lies is
very nice and she's very sweet and then
I started to explain the back story and
she said okay because it's really strong
and I said yeah so then
I start walking around and talking and
then uh like my son comes home and he's
like whoa what's happening in here and I
realized okay I should I'm gonna try and
tone this down a little bit so I got
some soap and water and was like washing
my throat and my under underneath my jaw
and um walking around nope that Jupe was
there to stay it was the equivalent it
was the uh it was the equivalent of
getting a tattoo and so then what I
didn't realize is that night sometimes
when I fall asleep I roll over onto my
stomach so I ground Jupe into my pillow
and my mattress and then three days
later
um I'm still smelling Jupe on our sheets
and I think they've been watched washed
so Joop is not something that you it's
not a decision you can take lightly
my Joop was with me for maybe six six to
seven days did you did you did it feel
like you were in bed with Tracy Morgan
it did yeah and you probably you enjoyed
I had a very erotic Adventure
my pillow yeah let's just put it that
way yeah okay what speaking of Tracy and
then later on you see me at a restaurant
opening a bottle of wine and it's me
with my pillow
the pillow's sitting opposite me
has me followed by a private detective
and he goes I got bad news for you he's
seeing some [ __ ] on the side and then he
she sees pictures of me with my pillow
[Laughter]
I take it to dinner a guy comes by with
a violin and he's playing while we're
I'm ordering the best champagne move it
into an apartment yeah that's right I
got you all set up in your own special
place with an allowance
now when I brought that jeep in last
week I left only to find that Tracy
Morgan that day a package arrived from
him yes this was great
I went home with the Joop which sounds
it does sound like I the class I came
home with the clap
I went to this house of ill repute and I
came home with the Juke
ah that guy that guy's lousy with the
Jew doctor you gotta help me
I got the Jew
uh so uh yeah Tracy sent me a bottle of
Jupe and a handwritten note really
lovely so you have dupe now at home and
in the office yeah I've got my home Jupe
and I got my work juice up yeah you're
drooped up for Dave yeah oh I'm all set
for Jupe although Tracy says to really
do this properly you've got to use half
a bottle with each application so I'm
really good for four days when you think
about it four years whoa all right well
anyway again our thanks to Tracy Morgan
for showing me this side of life I
didn't know I think maybe I am a Cologne
guy now and if anyone asks my cologne is
dupe why because you can put it on once
and it's there for life